Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Ebrar Batmaz
Merhaba.
50 yaşındayım.
Psikiyatrideki yirmi birinci yılım.
Bana büyük ikramiye annemin
karnındayken çıktı.
Nasıl mı?
Sağ gözüm gelişmemiş, görmüyor.
Bu yüzden çocukluğum doktor doktor gezerek
“Acaba bu göz görür mü?” diyerek geçti.
Bu da beni acılara ve dertlere
karşı duyarlı kıldı.
Bu duyarlılık, şimdi yaptığım
işte yolumu aydınlatıyor.
Yaşamdaki dezavantajları avantaja çevirme
hâli bence büyük ikramiye.
Nasıl mı doktor oldum?
Bir doktor nasıl yaşar bilmeden?
Başarılılar doktor oluyordu.
Ben de öyle yaptım
ama psikiyatrist olmayı
bile isteye seçtim
çünkü fakültede okurken
genel cerrahi stajında
kan fobim olduğu ortaya çıktı, bayıldım.
Stajlar ilerlerken midedeki ülserden çok
ruhtaki acıların ilgimi çektiğini
fark ettim.
Bir de benden birkaç yaş küçük kardeşimle
ilgili bir durum var.
Epeyce bir belirledi benim bu seçimimi.
Zorlu bir ergenlik geçiriyordu.
Küçük yaşta sigara içmeye başlamıştı,
okulu kırıyordu,
ders notları düşüyordu.
Annem ve babamla çok çatışıyordu.
Annemin şu sözleri aklımda:
“İyi söylüyorum, olmuyor,
kötü söylüyorum olmuyor.
Birisi olsa da bana ne
yapacağımı söylese.”
O yıllar Gaziantep’deyiz.
Çok da ulaşılabilecek
ruh sağlığı uzmanları yok.
Velhasıl 2000 yılında bütün tercihlerini,
TUS’daki bütün tercihlerini
psikiyatri yapmış olarak
psikiyatri uzmanlığını aldım
ve Gaziantep’te bir özel hastanede
göreve başladım.
İşe alınmam bir hayli ilginç.
İş görüşmesi için çağrıldığımda
genel müdürle beraber
büyük bir masanın etrafında
hastanenin kıdemli doktorlarının
toplandığını gördüm.
Hepsi erkektiler
ve bana pek çok soru sordular.
“Bakalım önce sen sağlam mısın,”
dercesine.
Tıpta hiçbir branşın böyle bir uygulamaya
maruz kaldığını duymadım.
Velhasıl, poliklinik yapmaya başladım
ama hasta yok.
Günde bir hasta var, iki hasta var.
Hemşire, sekreter deskine gidiyorum.
Koridorun sonuna bakıyorum,
acaba bu gelen bana doğru
yönelecek mi diye.
Bir iki hasta, bir iki hasta.
7 yıl sonra psikiyatri polikliniği,
hastanenin kardiyolojiden sonra
en çok hasta bakılan polikliniği oldu.
Bunu doğru psikiyatri uygulamalarının,
ulaşılabilir psikiyatri uygulamalarının
başarısı olarak görüyorum.
Çok da ulusal ya da dünyasal
bir durumdan farklı değil.
Zira daha birkaç yıl önceye kadar
Dünya Sağlık Örgütü;
ruhsal hastalıkların, depresyon gibi,
anksiyete gibi ruhsal hastalıkların
insanoğluna maliyeti en yüksek ikinci
hastalık grubu olduğunu söylüyordu.
Birinci sırada kardiyoloji
sorunları vardı.
İki yıl önce revize edildi.
Bir numaraya ruhsal hastalıklar geldi.
Biraz temel kavramlardan söz edeceğim.
Ruh sağlığı nedir?
Ruhsal temel ihtiyaçlar nedir?
Çok da uzatmadan
ama temelde ruhsal ihtiyaç,
dertlerimiz için yardım almayı
normalleştirme, olağanlaştırma
hâlini anlatmaya çalışacağım size.
Ruh sağlığının herkesin üzerinde
anlaştığı bir temel tanımı yok.
Pek çok kişiye ya da pek çok
kurama göre değişik
ama benim en çok kabul ettiğim
sevebilme ve üretebilme hâli.
Üretebilme hâli bazen bir çorbayı,
bazen bilimsel bir teoriyi,
bazen de bir melodiyi.
Sevebilme hâli ise, özden verebilme hâli.
Bu sıralarda pek duymadığımız,
eskiden çok kullandığımız
özverili olma hâli aslında.
Ruhsal rahatsızlıklar,
temel ruhsal ihtiyaçlarımız
karşılanmadığında ortaya çıkıyorlar
ve temel ruhsal ihtiyaçlarımız;
sevilme hâli, beğenilme hâli,
birlikte olma hâli
ve ait olma hâli.
Bu dördünden bir ya da birkaçı
yeterince duyurulmadığında
ruhsal olarak hastalanıyoruz.
Yeterince diyorum çünkü dünya,
insanoğlunun kurduğu düzen
aslında bütün insanların
temel ruhsal ihtiyaçlarını
bütünüyle karşılayacak güçte değil.
Kaynaklar kısıtlı.
Annemiz tek, babamız tek, gıda kısıtlı,
ekonomi para kısıtlı vesaire vesaire.
Bu yüzden yeterince karşılanmasından
söz edebiliriz.
Ruhsal ihtiyaçlar karşılandılar,
karşılanmadılar hastalandık.
Aynı zamanda ruhsal ihtiyaçların
kültür ve gelenek tarafından da
belirlendiğini biliyoruz.
Çok yaygın bir görüş var.
Ruh, psike, zihin çok bireysel;
bu yüzden de ruhsal meseleler
çok bireysel.
Hayır, öyle değil.
Büyük fotoğrafla da çok fazla ilgili
çünkü büyüdüğünüz kültür,
büyüdüğünüz geleneksel arka plan
ve sahip olduğunuz adalet,
hukuk sistemi de sizin ruhsal
dertlerinizi belirliyor.
Birkaç küçük örnek vereceğim.
Ben Anadolu’da
2000 yılında göreve başladığımda
poliklinikte bir genç kadın gördüm.
İyi giyimli, çalışıyor, eğitimli,
kolundaki ve boynundaki
morlukları bana anlatıyor, gösteriyor.
Eşinden şiddete maruz kalmış.
Ben onun ruhsal olarak
kendini güçlü hissetmesi,
güvende hissetmesi ile ilgili
telkinlerde bulunarak eve yolladım.
Bir sonraki görüşmeye kolu alçıda geldi
çünkü eve gittiğinde
kendini daha değerli ve güvende hissederek
eşine karşı daha palazlı davranmıştı
ve eşi de şiddetin boyutunu arttırmıştı.
Dolayısıyla sunduğumuz çözümler
eğer halkta, kültürde, yasada,
ekonomide karşılık bulunmuyorsa
çok da iyi çareler olamıyorlar.
Bir başka örnek de,
ergenler ile çalışırken
karşılaştığım durumlar.
Ergenler, anne baba çatışmaları nedeniyle
polikliniğe getiriyorlar
ama ben ergenliği “ergen dezavantajlı grup
ebeveynlerine karşı” deyip
ergenleri koruyucu
bir tutum içine giriyorum
çünkü Batı tıbbı, Batı psikiyatrisi
biraz da bunu öğretiyor bize.
Fakat bir sonraki görüşmeye
gençler gelmiyor,
anne babalar geliyorlar.
Ne olduğunu sorduğumda da
bana diyorlar ki,
“Hocam sizden sonra
bizi hiç dinlemez oldu.”
Anladım ki ergenlerin yanında
yer alıyorken ben
evde anne babaların otoritesini sarsmışım
çünkü bizim kültürde
hiyerarşik düzen çok önemli.
Bizim kültürde,
anne babalar yaşları kaç olursa olsun
çocuklarına bakım vermeye devam ediyor.
Maddeten bakım vermeye devam ediyorlar,
maneviyaten bakım vermeye devam ediyorlar
ve bizim kültürümüzde çocuklar
kaç yıl yaşarlarsa yaşasınlar,
hangi ekonomik ya da eğitim seviyesinde
olurlarsa olsunlar,
ebeveynlerinin
yol göstericiliğine uyuyorlar.
Eğer ben tedaviye bunu ortak etmezsem
ruhsal dertlere çare bulurken
bu kültürün,
bu coğrafyanın doktoru olamam,
ruh sağlığı uygulayıcısı olamam.
İşte bütün bunların etrafında şekillendi
benim psikiyatristliğim
ve sayı da kardiyoloji vakalarının
sayısına yaklaştı.
Konuşmamızın ana başlığına gelirsek.
Gerektiğinde yardım almak,
yemek yemek kadar doğaldır.
Dikkat ederseniz ruhsal dertler için
yardım istemeyi
çok fazla olağanlaştırmaya
çalışıyoruz bu başlıkta.
Demek ki ne kadar normal dışı
algılıyoruz bunu.
Biliyoruz ki ruhsal dertler
irade meselesi olarak görülürler
ve yaşayanlarda utanca
ve suçluluğa sebep olurlar
ve bu duygu; utanç duygusu,
suçlanma duygusu evrensel.
Bunun yaşanmadığı bir ülke,
bir ekonomik topluluk,
bir cinsiyet ya da bir etnik köken yok.
Her yerde, dünyanın her yerinde
ruhsal dertleri
böyle bir ayrımcılığa maruz bırakıyoruz.
İrade meselesi olarak görüyoruz.
Kişinin belirlediği elinde olan
bir şey olarak görüyoruz.
Biz insanlar az değiliz
çünkü aslında
bütün hastalıklara bu muameleyi yapıyoruz.
Örneğin obeziteye de bunu yapıyoruz.
Diyoruz ki,
obezler iradesi zayıf insanlar.
İnsan nasıl olur da yemek
yemesini kontrol edemez?
Sonra bakıyoruz ki bunun
genetik kökeni var.
Bakıyoruz ki bunun başka bedensel
hastalıklarla ilgisi var.
O zaman obeziteyle ilgili
görüşümüz değişiyor.
Öte yandan, pankreasımız insülin
salgılamadığında diyabet oluyoruz
ve diyabetin tedavisi için dışarıdan
insülin kullanmayı kabul ediyoruz.
Vücudumuzda bir eksiklik varsa
onu yerine koyarak tedavi olabilirim
ama beynimizin frontal lobu düşüncelerden
ve duygulardan sorumlu
frontal lobu serotonin sağlamadığında
depresyona yakalanıyoruz.
Bunun yerine koyma tedavisi de
antidepresanlarla kabul etmiyoruz.
O da hastalık,
bu da hastalık.
Aslında bütün bir gün boyunca
hastanelerin kapısından giren kişilerin
ortalama üçte birinin
ruhsal dertler nedeniyle
orada olduklarını biliyoruz.
Yani aslında bedensel bir sorunu var gibi
görünüyor ama arka plan ruhsal.
Özellikle bizimki gibi ülkelerde
duyguyu ve düşünceyi çok tanıyarak
ve de dışa vurarak
büyütülmediğimiz yerlerde
bu durum çok daha yaygın.
Örneğin, ben poliklinikte
çarpıntı ve kaygı arasındaki ilişkiyi
hastalarıma anlatırken
“Hocam hiç kaygım yok,
hiçbir şey için kaygılanmıyorum,
hiç de korkmuyorum
ama sadece kalbim çarpıyor,”
sözünü çok fazla duymuşumdur.
Peki ne zaman yardım almalıyız?
Şöyle somutlaştırmak istiyorum,
acaba aranızda ne kadarınızın
karnı guruldamıştır?
Peki ne kadarınız
bu karın gurultusundan utanmıştır?
bu karın gurultusu nedeniyle
arkadaşlarıyla
sinemaya gitmek istememiştir,
okula gitmek istememiştir,
işe gitmek istememiştir?
Ya da ne kadarınız
burada olduğunuza göre
pek bu olasılık yok
ama karnı guruldadığı için,
utandığı için evden dışarı çıkamamıştır?
İşte ruhsal rahatsızlıklar;
kişinin kendiyle kurduğu ilişki,
toplumla kurduğu ilişki
ve işiyle kurduğu ilişkide bozulmalar,
yaşadığı hâller aslında.
Buradaki bozukluklar üzerinden bakıp
yardım alma kararını oluşturabiliriz.
Eninde sonunda yardım alıyoruz
ama biliyor musunuz,
depresif bir bozukluk için
ortalama sekiz yıl gecikmiş olarak.
Endişe bozuklukları için ise
ortalama dokuz yıl gecikmiş olarak
ve ne yazık ki bu gecikmelerin tedaviye
cevabını da etkilediğini biliyoruz.
Daha derin bir yaranın iyileşmesinin
daha geç olması gibi.
Eninde sonunda bütün engelleri aşıp
ruhsal olarak
yardım almaya karar verdiğimizde
kimlerden yardım alıyoruz biliyor musunuz?
Dörtte birimiz din adamlarından,
dörtte birimiz pratisyenlerden.
Dörtte birimiz aralarında
psikiyatristlerin de bulunduğu
ruh sağlığı çalışanlarından.
Dörtte birimiz de
yardımcı tıp elemanlarından.
İki tanesi önemli,
din adamları ve yardımcı tıp elemanları.
Din adamları için şunu söyleyebilirim.
Meseleyi bir irade meselesi olarak
görüyorsanız,
doğal olarak inançlarınız üzerinden
iradenizi güçlendirmeye çalışırsınız
ve bunun üzerinden ruhsal
dertlerinize çare alırsınız.
Üstelik din adamları,
ruh sağlığı çalışanlarına göre
çok daha fazla sayıdalar,
çok daha kolay ulaşılabilirler
ve bedavalar.
Diğer tıp çalışanları,
yardımcı sağlık çalışanları meselesi;
koçlar, yaşam koçları, fitoterapistler,
astrologlar.
Bunlar pozitif bilimin,
yani kanıta dayalı
bilimin henüz hızlıca çözemediği,
kolayca çözemediği ama çözebildiği
durumlardaki açıklardan yararlanan,
umut tacirliği yapan kişiler.
Lütfen ruh sağlığınızı
bilime ve deneyime emanet edin.
Bir hastamın sözleriyle
tamamlamak istiyorum.
Çeşitli derecede ruhsal
hastalıklar vardır.
Hiçbirimiz bunlar için doğal
bağışıklık taşımayız.
Hepimizin başına gelebilir.
“Ruhsal dertlerim olduğunu bilmeden
önce herkes beni severdi.
Bir ailem var, işim var.
Peki şimdi ne değişti?
Ben hâlâ aynı kişiyim.
Eğer zahmet edip sorsalardı
bir psikiyatristle görüşme nedenim,
uykusuzluğumdu.”
Psikiyatristler hâlâ altı yıllık tıp,
beş yıllık uzmanlık eğitimlerinin ardından
ülkemizdeki en sistematik
eğitim alan ruh sağlığı çalışanları.
Her ne kadar
hemen ilaç yazmaya meyilli,
hemen tanı koymaya meyilli,
bir bakışta içimizin röntgenini çeken,
aklımızdan geçenleri okuyabilen kişiler
olarak bilinsek de biz psikiyatristler,
adımız çıkmış dokuza inmez sekize misali,
hâlâ en güvenilir durumdayız
bilimsel olarak.
Lütfen yardım almanızı geciktirmeyin.
Teşekkürler.